Friendship, family, and fun…
What do these words have in common?
They’re integral parts of the human experience,
and also share the same first letter.
Our ancestors thousands of years in the past
may have struggled to pronounce these words,
as the “f” sound would have been cumbersome
to produce.
Sounds like “f” or “v” are called
labiodentals: labio, relating to your lips,
and dentals, your teeth.
They are produced when you raise your bottom
lip to touch your upper teeth.
Labiodentals are used in over half of the
languages spoken around the world today, but
before shifts in food-processing technology,
these sounds may not have been as common.
Before the Neolithic, food was minimally processed,
and required more effort to chew.
This constant gnashing meant teeth wore down
more, resulting in what is known as an edge-to-edge
bite by adolescence.
Then came the emergence of food processing
technologies.
Gone were the days of laborious chewing, as
stews, preserved food, and ground grain as flour
became more common.
Softer food meant less wear and tear on the
teeth, and the preservation of an overbite,
a vertical overlap of the teeth and an overjet,
horizontal overlapping of the teeth, which
humans are normally born with.
Researchers created a biomechanical model
of an edge-to-edge bite, aligned top and bottom
teeth, and an overjet and overbite to see
if one provided an advantage for articulating labiodentals.
They found that the edge-to-edge configuration
would have required more effort to produce
a labiodental, as the distance from the bottom
lip and top teeth would have been greater.
The preservation of an overbite and overjet
also increased the likelihood that a labiodental
would be made on accident--like saying “f”
instead of “p.”
Today, nearly all societies have access to
softer foods, and most people retain their
overbite and overjet throughout their lifetimes.
This makes producing labiodentals easier,
but historically not all languages have had
these sounds.
Nowadays, many languages are acquiring labiodental
sounds like “f” and “v” through contact
with other languages that have them.
One example includes West Greenlandic speakers
who have been in long sustained contact with
European languages, including Danish.
This study shows how language can be shaped
by changes in human biology.
In the future, researchers hope to better
understand not only how this language change
took place, but why.
Some data suggests that labiodentals served
as an indicator of social class, proving advantageous
to those who adopted the sound.
In the meantime, thank your local food processor
for being able to say those “f words”